Secretary of State Anthony blinken spoke
with Chief Foreign Affairs correspondent
and faced the nation moderator Margaret
Brennan after granna's release Margaret
asked about the potential consequences
of this prisoner swap and if Whelan was
part of the negotiation process
the choice wasn't between getting one
American or the other back it was the
choice before us was one or none and the
president decided that it was important
to at least bring Brittany home now and
continue to work on getting Paul back
too the past three administrations have
conducted prisoner swaps but one of the
criticisms here is that Victor boot was
so high profile and he was clearly of
high interest to Russia Brittany Greiner
is a celebrity so she got a lot of
attention in this transaction did you
somehow up the price on the head of
another American by showing that Russia
can get something it really wants if it
just kidnaps and holds hostage the right
American two things Margaret first as
you noted at the outset in any of these
situations unfortunately the other side
gets a vote the other side gets a veto
and the Russians have used that as we
propose different uh ways of doing this
second we can bring people home as we
did and yet also work and take action to
deter this from happening going forward
in the future
Margaret Brennan joins us now with more
on the response to greiner's release so
Margaret what did you make of secretary
blinken's response to your question
well Nate in arguing that this wasn't a
concession but rather it was the only
option on the table the administration
is admitting here that Russia had the
upper hand and they wouldn't budge and
what's so frustrating about these
hostage cases is you have ordinary
Americans in this case a celebrity who
are carrying one thing and that's a U.S
passport and that puts a price on their
head and it can be used as leverage
against an American President Vladimir
Putin was not under pressure to bring
his citizen home President Biden was
hmm we heard Paul Whelan saying Nancy's
report uh Margaret that his bags were
packed he's ready to go what did
secretary blinken tell you about the
efforts that are ongoing to free him
well Gail there were many options put on
the table including back in the summer a
two for two swap the administration had
tried two for two two for one and Russia
wouldn't budge on that
um and so there were other Russians
offered up in potential trades and the
the Kremlin just wasn't interested so
it's not clear Gail if there is another
card to play at this point on behalf of
the U.S because they just used Victor
boot arguably one of their most powerful
and so it's not clear secretary blinken
did say they hope and will keep trying
but he also made clear this was just a
single transaction no more no less and
there's no diplomatic breakthrough
attached to it
all right Margaret there's certainly
more to come on this story we thank you
so much